how about pete davidson talk about body
bags let me tell you he's with kim k he
dude with you know
he's not the sexiest guy in there
there's no way there's no way dude kate
beckinsale [ __ ] ariana grande kim
kardashian yeah brian brian will attest
to this i know you i could tell you this
i know you've never been to staten
island and i know you've never been to
staten island i'm going to rhode island
soon
i said listen
never say that again why not because
never ever say god i'm going to rhode
island because you're correlating rhode
island with staten island no i'm not
saying it's kind of same no no that area
is island this island so yeah it's like
saying how far how far away are they how
far is staten island rhode island well
there's rhode island right now about
four hours four or five hours four or
five hours yeah but but they're both
kind of not
unlike a lot of guests yeah unlike a lot
of guests like i post i repost you don't
have to even tell me i want this as my
throat i appreciate it
never he's right you might even want to
because you might want to edit that we
want to cut that out oh no i don't give
a [ __ ] okay okay no anyway back to you
have you ever been to staten island yes
how many many times my aunt lived there
so i would go there all day okay but
because you actually actually did it
randomly i did a play there which is
really funny okay she's the mayor of
outside of outside of your aunt being
there and doing a play there desperate
for work because if you're doing a plan
island which i was i was 24. the part
the point is this
nobody's going to staten island really
unless you're tapping that ass
period that's true nobody is going to
stash no she was in new york but then
i've i've been in staten island i'm 51
i've lived in new york my whole life
i've been to staten island one time
one time
for work it's a suburb it's it's just
it's just there's nothing to do it's
statin italy it's it used to be now did
you see uh the king of staten island
with judd avatar it was good it was good
like that yeah it was [ __ ] good but
when we talk about the uh vales or
whatever
yeah yeah
um but when we talk about a stick man
i'm not saying because they tried to say
the other day he was like the warren
beatty of his generation you can't it
takes decades to do what warren beatty
does now he he's had three if he i'm i'm
saying it right here he's [ __ ] kim
kardashian you think so there's no
friends
he's [ __ ] kim kardashian and or he
[ __ ] her and then they might just be
it might be a short-term thing whatever
he's got that notch in his bow so we
have ariana grande and kim kardashian
right there so we're not saying we're
going to tell you yeah kate you're gonna
throw a cake because also jesus christ
banging and british right yeah they like
him for his vulnerability but you know
you know big dick energy came from him
ariana grande says he has big dick
energy and that's where all the big dick
energy [ __ ] came from yeah
right
so if so i'm saying right now you don't
go to staten island
just to hang out just to hang out
there's no good you got an aunt or
you're desperate for whatever i can't
remember any and by the way when i say
you go there all the time see my aunt
that's a lie you know that's a lie
that's why breeze passed it yeah because
right because you don't have that kind
of compassion or love in your life
i went there
maybe twice when i was a kid on what's
your name
you've been there three times i've been
there let's be honest in 52 years been
there twice maybe what's your aunt's
name aunt marie ann marie
your best way probably because you
didn't see her enough you hated her and
maybe i never went to see her you know
what i mean so it all depends it depends
i was just did you even do a play though
chicago on staten island
i was still at the neighborhood
playhouse on 54th street i'm still doing
you know what no one cares brian i'm
sorry
[ __ ] are you talking about this train
this is before i went to london and i
did because i'm a trained thespian which
is why my voice can carry so well
because i'm used to doing projects when
you're projecting my stage i this is
this is my stage boys i could see you
doing like a shakespeare thing i know it
would be [ __ ] up it'd be like is this
guy playing
you know